-So, now, it's
the end of the week.
That's usually when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
-Mm-hmm, things like checking
your inbox,
returning some e-mails,
and thank-you notes.
-Yes. Yes, I'll write some
thank-you notes. I was behind.
Running behind today.
I was just wondering if I could
write out some thank-you notes
right now.
You guys mind?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
Is it cool if I write some too?
-Of course. You have to.
-Okay. Yes, I'm here.
-Here we go. Can we get some
thank-you-note
writing music, please?
♪♪
Beautiful.
-Mm-hmm.
-It's beautiful. Here we go.
Thank you, dimmer switches,
for letting me feel like I'm
deejaying my living room.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
Okay. Me, me, me.
-Go, go, go.
-Okay.
Thank you, birthday candles,
for being crayons
that like to get lit.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This is fun.
-Yes.
-Here we go. Alright.
Thank you, clothes steamers,
or as I like to call you,
shirt Botox.
There you go.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Okay, okay.
-Alright.
-Thank you, the phrase,
"let me check my calendar,"
for being the prequel
to the word "no."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Ah. "Yeah, let me check
my calendar."
-Yes. "No."
-Yeah, no, I can't do it.
Alright, here we go.
-Boom.
-Thank you, steel wool,
for looking like a loofah
for robots.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Okay. Okay.
Thank you, postcards,
for making the government
deliver my Instagram.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I guess that is true.
That's what they are.
I like this one.
Thank you, Kim Kardashian's
new skin-toned headphones,
because when I have earbuds in,
I want people to not see them
and try to talk to me.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Oh, I didn't realize
you were wearing --"
"What? I got -- I got a pod --"
-I'll never, like, okay.
So, I saw Kim.
[ Laughter ]
I saw Kim Kardashian post
these ear pods.
I thought they were
organic eggs.
[ Laughter ]
-You thought she's selling eggs?
-I didn't know what was
happening. I didn't know.
She had a deal with Whole Foods.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. You're up.
Sorry, you're up.
-Okay, is it me?
-Yeah.
-Okay, thank you, drinks labeled
elixir, for being shorthand for
"you're about to drop $8
on apple juice."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-They sneak that in there.
Oh, it's an elixir. Yeah.
Alright. Here we go.
Thank you, Swiss Army knives,
for being one knife,
one bottle opener, and 37 other
things I'll never use.
There you go.
What am I gonna do with this?
[ Applause ]
-Okay.
-Alright, bud. Here we go.
Thank you, Earth, for taking hot
girl summer way too literally.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah, oh, my God.
It's too hot. It is too hot!
That's my thank-you notes.